ascendance has no shortage of amazing
boyfriends in fact Duggan men are so
charming that they make us all want to
fairy tale romance choosing between Ben
and Doug isn't an easy thing to do
because let's face it they're both
perfect in their own way still we just
had to put these two guys head-to-head
in a boyfriend battle he's busy so watch
until the end to tell us who you like
best Ben or dud round one first
impression first impressions are
important and they are even more
important in a love story sometimes they
are sweet and full of chemistry but a
lot of times they are super awkward both
Ben and Doug were less than smooth when
they met their future girlfriends let's
take a look Ben is obviously nervous
when he meets the v case for the first
time and the kids from the aisle are
trying really hard not to look impressed
at all he has prepared a speech it's so
good to finally meet you all but when he
meets mal he totally freezes for a
moment he was definitely into her right
off the bat mal looks really confused by
his reaction but he recovers pretty
quickly he continues with his big speech
but mal doesn't care about the speeches
she asks where the bathrooms are instead
he asks her if his speech was
over-the-top and she agrees that it was
but then he drops this smooth line about
first impressions mal definitely notices
how cute he is after that just then Ben
notices mouth
Doug immediately notices Evie he
introduced himself as dopey son and
lists all of the dorms but before he
gets to sneezy he just totally freezes
he is completely enamored by Evie he
says which might as well be a swear word
for him Evie plays it up and flirts he
recovers pretty quickly to give them the
info they need but he continues to stare
at Evie for a while ground to hero
status girls may love a knight in
shining armor but those are pretty hard
to find
still everyone loves a hero and Ben and
Doug are both heroes in their own way
Ben is a really noble guy he stands up
for those who can't stand up for
themselves that's why he gets the V case
to come to our 'adam crap I've decided
that the children on the Isle of the
Lost be given a chance to live here and
over time and he doesn't like Audrey's
sneaky ways Ben really stepped up his
game in descendants two and see
proves just how heroic he can be when
Mao runs away to the aisle then insists
on going after her he could literally
send an army to retrieve her being King
and all but he wants to get mal on his
own so Ben joins the other V Ches as
they travel to the Isle of the Lost
and then he fights off pirates who knew
Ben could wield a sword it was pretty
epic and now is definitely impressed
Doug's hero status is a bit more subtle
but he does save Evie from her own mind
after all Evie was convinced that she
wasn't smart enough but Doug never
doubted her for a second when Evie is
accused of cheating with the magic
mirror
Doug stands up for her he jumped at the
chance to defend her and convinces their
chemistry teacher to give her the
benefit of the doubt the teacher was
willing to take Chad's word for it and
expel the villain but Doug didn't let it
happen it's not easy to stand up to a
teacher especially for a shy guy like
Doug but Evie was super thankful it was
after she passed her test that Evie
really noticed Doug and he asks her to
hang out and study smooth Doug round
three swoon Factor there's no doubt that
Ben and Doug are both the sweetest guys
however only one of them can win this
contest so who has the ability to make a
girl swoon let's take a look at Doug he
really sees Evie for how awesome she is
he knows she's smart and he's pretty
smart too he wants her to be successful
and independent in descendants - Doug
runs the numbers for Evie's fashion
business
he tells her that in a few years she
should be able to buy the castle she
wants that way he says she won't need a
prince he takes her hand and it's so
sweet and the way he looks at her is so
amazing Evie knows she has it good she
says that of course she doesn't need a
prince because she has Doug and then
there's Ben he is one romantic guy and
he knows how to make a girl feel special
he went out of his way to plan his first
date with mal
he surprises her with a picnic in the
woods mal is shocked to say the least
the way Ben looks at mouths adorable he
treats her with the utmost respect
he's a gentleman who's prone to being
slightly flirtatious and that's what we
like about him grounds for flaws some
might say that Ben and Doug are
absolutely perfect however there is no
such thing as perfection
so both these dream
have their own set of flaws which block
could you live with Doug has a streak of
jealousy it probably comes from his low
self-esteem but when Evie goes to rescue
Ben on the Isle his jealous streak comes
out Carlos and Jay lie and tell Doug
that Evie went camping Doug is confused
at first Evie is not exactly an
outdoorsy girl but when she returns he
barges into a room he tells her all the
reasons that he would have made a great
camping partner he asks why she went
without him once
Evie tells him the truth he calms down
just a little but he still isn't
convinced she isn't seeing someone else
he asks if she has seen happy Sun and
goes on to tell her that he isn't that
great of a guy jealousy isn't a good
look on you Doug then there's them he's
a pretty great guy
but he isn't always honest in the first
movie mal puts him under a love spell
but it washes off on their first date he
lets her think that he is still under
the spell he doesn't tell her and tell
the coronation he tells her the truth
only after she gives him an anti love
potion
mal still would have liked him if he
told her the truth and she wouldn't have
had all those conflicting feelings but
mal wasn't exactly innocent in the
situation either come on guys honesty is
always the best policy we know it's a
hard choice spend and Doug are both
amazing guys and they are even better
boyfriends mal and Evie are two lucky
girls but now that we've put these two
head-to-head it's time for you to decide
tell us in the comments who you think
won The Descendants boyfriends battle
before you go make sure to give this
video a big thumbs up and while you're
at it hit that subscribe button thanks
for watching the things we'll catch you
next time
[Music]